hey guys just a quick video today last
week I made a video talking about my
schedule and thinking about making some
changes on the YouTube channel and I
really appreciate all the feedback that
you guys gave both in terms of
encouraging me to to try my new vision
as well as just the love that you guys
have for the channel and wanting to
protect it and make sure that it's still
you know high-value content it really
means a lot the comments were
overwhelming and I feel the love and and
and it means a lot to me so thank you
guys for doing that I'm going to be
making a couple changes to the channel
and and I look forward to your feedback
as we launch it and see if you like it
or don't let me know here's what I'm
gonna change you know I felt like I wish
there was something out there that I
could use as part of my daily routine to
help me think bigger to help me want to
do something that kind of stretches my
comfort zone and introduces a new
thought a new way of thinking that that
you know maybe I'm not used to but that
also doesn't take an hour to get into
and I really I haven't found it I didn't
want something just that was the
motivation of rah rah you can do it you
know somebody yelling at your face I
know that works to some people but
doesn't work for me you know I get
inspired more by stories of people doing
great things you know surround myself
with greatness and I think if you can
surround yourself with greatness you're
more likely to do great things and I
just haven't found it I haven't found
that anywhere and so enough you know
complaining about it do something about
it and so what I'm going to be changing
on my channel is one changing the time
so I do two videos a day the first one
is now going to be at seven in the
morning so that's eastern time so
depending on you know where you're
living hopefully you can start your day
with the morning video
the second is going to be at five
o'clock in the afternoon the morning
video is going to be something again
that is uh challenge you to think bigger
and something that inspires me something
that I feel personally inspired by it
i'm going to share why i'm inspired by
it and then run a clip a lot of times I
get inspired by famous entrepreneurs and
there's a special clip that I've seen
I'm going to include that as well and
then the afternoon video is going to be
more tactical hands on answering your
questions the stuff that you have guests
been used to so the morning kind of wake
up get a spark of energy give you some a
hit of entrepreneur caffeine to go out
and and continue on your day and do
something awesome and then the afternoon
one the practical hands-on answering
your questions and giving you some tips
to help you grow your business so I'm
still playing around with it it's not
going to be perfect I'm sure I'm going
to make a lot of mistakes I really
appreciate your support as we transition
through this and feel free to leave
comments you know let me know what you
think about not just this video but the
new schedule as the videos come out give
me suggestions tips ideas I really
appreciate it I'm making this selfishly
for myself and I'm hoping that you guys
will enjoy and it'll help you with your
business as well so I'm excited today is
Wednesday I don't know when it's going
to actually be launching this video but
today is my wednesday i'm going to be
filming today the new series i'm really
excited and so here we go i'm gonna hit
back out it rubber bah i'm gonna head
back inside and start filming